I get great views on shorts but not long
form what will help me transition views
from short form to long form well
there's an analytic that you need to see
and if you go to analytics overview
content and at the top make sure you're
selected all you'll scroll down there's
this thing that says viewers across
formats
and you can then see what percentage of
my viewers watch my videos versus my
lives views versus my shorts
so on this particular Channel think
media podcast 76 percent of people watch
videos only so this is a long form
Channel that's basically eight out of
ten don't care that I upload shorts on
this channel one out of ten people on
think media podcast Channel don't make
it to the long form they only watch the
shorts this whole idea of that shorts
viewers are gonna conform uh convert to
long form I think that people
overestimate they try to force it they
try to do commercials they try to say go
watch long form video they try to do a
lot of stuff and it's there's a lot of
friction in that world but there is a
new feature that allows you to solve
this so what you can actually do is you
can go into the short itself and you
could go over on this right side it says
related video this is kind of cool so
you now have an area where you can do a
related video
and you can connect to a YouTube short
the full length video I'm gonna take
this YouTube link I'm going to come back
over here
I'm going to connect that I'm going to
click save
and now this video is now connected to a
little clickable link right here that
says don't get sued and if people click
that from the YouTube short it takes
them to the full length conversation
this is a big deal for anybody that's
doing clips from a video podcast anybody
that's doing I should say shorts yeah
Snippets short video YouTube shorts from
any kind of long form content now you've
just connected the two did you see how
that worked two things number one I've
had too much coffee today number two if
you have not seen our free master class
yet you're gonna love it if you're
serious about growing your YouTube
channel just go to
thinkmasterclass.com for a one hour Deep
dive on-demand YouTube strategy class
it's sick and uh I'm gonna go refill my
coffee hope to see you on the class